I uh I'm Banksy God that felt good
now no you're not
Justin ten years ago the Academy
introduced the best animated feature
category and awarded the first Oscar to
Shrek Mia and I are delighted to be here
to present the Oscars for Best Animated
Feature and Best Animated Short you know
we can't really do it with this this
backdrop it's just it's all wrong
it's not even animating that's a good
point yeah I'm sure they make an app for
that I just do you think yeah
hey yeah it's put up right here
ladies and gentlemen I give you Shrek
the land a far far away right here right
now that's that's amazing
I know thank you oh hey um I'm so sorry
you kind of missed a spot
we're here the nominees for best
animated short film
day and night
Teddy Newton The Gruffalo
Jacob shoe and Max Langley let's pollute
jeef we bow to the lost thing Shawn 10
and Andrew roomin Madagascar carne de
voyage Madagascar a journey diary
Bastian Du Bois
and the Oscar goes to you no no no tell
me what nevermind she's the lost thing
Shaun tan and Angela Roman
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Sean tan and Andrew women
wow this is quite surreal our film is
about a creature that nobody pays any
attention to so this is wonderfully
ironic the award really goes to our
producer so if you burned the true
champion of this project for the past
ten years alongside Andrew and our
splendid animation team of Leo Baeck and
Tom Bryant the Oscar also goes to John
Kerr said Mike Wazowski
Adrien murderers Tim Minchin Screen
Australia and everybody who's supported
us with such generosity and patience
many thanks to our families and friends
to my wife Inari Minotaur Costanza Noah
and to Perth and Melbourne this one's
for you - thank you very quick one just
say I love my wife Jennifer needle who's
up there and my business partner and
great friend Jonathan bats egg and
everybody at passion pictures and this
is dedicated to all lost things
everywhere thank you thanks Academy